[Music]
tyler welcome to the show
thank you for taking my call yeah sure
what's going on
i have a question about some collections
okay on
all right how many uh bills do you have
in collections
uh it's about 10 and the total is about
19 000.
19 000. what kind of debt is this
uh
medical bills student loans uh were from
a credit union that i loaned out in
after i graduated high school
a few old car loans and a few personal
loans okay
and what got you to this point have you
uh one when was the last time you paid
on these and what made you stop
uh never paid on them
you never never made a single payment on
any of this
no did you have intention to oh yes of
course of course and what happened
i just
didn't get around to it forgot all about
it then i started getting them in the
mail i was like okay i need to start
paying these and i just want to know
which one should i do first
well have they been contacting you for a
while now are these old
oh yeah they're very old some like five
years old six years old
seven years old
okay well number one we've got to be
proactive and get in touch with them and
communicate
but they haven't been knocking down your
door calling you any of that
oh no just i got a few letters in the
mail a couple a couple days ago and i
said i need to start paying them okay
and i totaled them all down and yeah is
that all of your the debt that you have
currently
the 19 000
yes what do you do for a living
real estate okay how old are you
26.
all right what's your income
about 150. 150. so you could pay this
debt off pretty fast
yeah real bad what's holding you back
uh i don't know which order to do them
in if it is an ordinance to do it like
uh the ramsey way
well we have the debt snowball method
which means you're paying them off
smallest to largest
okay so that's one way to do it to knock
it out and make some
progress okay should i add them in the
uh monthly budget absolutely are any of
these federal student loans
no uh it was just one big one it was
like 3 000 from my local credit union
do you have any money in savings any
money what's your liquid cash total
liquor cash about
10 000
okay
is investment
investments are they retirement or
non-retirement
retirement it's a roth ira okay it's all
retirement
okay and where is the 150 going each
month
uh you said you're doing a budget
no not really okay we're gonna help you
with that for sure because you have a
great income there's no reason to to be
in debt you can pay cash for all of
these things going forward and clean up
this mess
do you feel any shame or guilt about
those past decisions and not paying them
i feel guilty yeah most definitely
because it should have been down by now
yeah i think that's part of the reason
you've ignored it
yeah right
let's put it in the drunk drawer and
let's not worry about that until someone
comes knocking
right right right you're absolutely
right well i think the best thing for
your future is to clean up this mess and
never look back and never touch debt
again you have a fantastic income you
got a bright future ahead of you and
those debts they don't define you
right
that's not who you are
tyler's a man of his word he's a man who
pays his bills on time he's a man who
pays cash for things and so i want you
to have that in your mind of the guy
that you're becoming and the identity
that you want to have going forward and
part of that is communicating with the
all the collections agencies and going
hey listen i'm sorry i haven't paid this
i'm ready to make good please confirm
the debt amounts
i need proof of all the debts that i
have out there and i will pay them
and then get on a plan
because right now you got 10k out of the
19. uh if you're following the baby
steps that means a thousand dollar
starter emergency fund which means
you've got 9 000 to throw this debt you
can cut it in half today
okay and you might be able to negotiate
the medical debt down and there may be
statutes of limitations but it's all
gonna include you being real intentional
and doing your homework and getting on
the phone and sending some emails and
being proactive
and it's gonna feel so good once you've
done that especially it's 19k and you
make 150 you can knock this out quickly
and the amount of peace you're gonna
find from just getting these little
ankle biters out of your life it's like
you will be able to just take a a deep
breath and not feel like they're kind of
haunting you like you said they're like
in the junk drawer where you don't
really want to see them but you know
that they're there and you feel a lot of
shame and guilt around them well i think
within easily six months you could have
these completely knocked out and be
building your emergency fund and moving
on to truly being wealth and just have a
completely different outlook on your
finances
so tyler your take-home pay based on
some rough numbers i'm guessing is about
eight or nine thousand when you average
it out
average yeah that's about average money
right so how quickly can we save up the
other 10 000 and knock this out
we're talking three months max
yeah i was um thinking before um
thanksgiving i like that i love that
that's going to give you a lot to be
thankful for but here's what this means
it means we're pausing investing it
means we're not eating out we're going
to look at every single dollar coming in
we're going to give it a plan and that's
why i want you to start doing a budget
i'm going to gift you every dollar
premium
which will connect to your bank it'll
bring all the transactions in and your
job is to have your income on one side
and all of your expenses on the other
and you make a plan and then you're
gonna take out eating out take out
investments take out subscriptions for a
short season while we clean up this mess
and it's gonna you're gonna be there
faster than you know it
okay i also have another question
exactly
um about purchasing the house
when should i start that after paying
off everything right
pay off everything then you're going to
build a three to six month emergency
fund
i would lean towards six months just so
you have a lot of financial peace in
your life because you haven't had that
with all this debt hanging around your
neck and once you have six months of
expenses
not income but expenses then we can
begin the process of saving up a down
payment for the house and i want you to
do it the smart way you're in real
estate so you know this process
right but also real estate agents can
make some bad decisions too can't they
they absolutely can i'm an example
so here's what i want you to do don't
buy the craziest nicest house and don't
take all the money the bank will give
you do it the smart way i want you to do
a 15-year fixed-rate conventional
mortgage
and i want the payment to be no more
than
a quarter of your take-home pay so we
mentioned let's say it's eight grand
we're talking two thousand dollars a
month on a 15-year mortgage and then
that'll dictate how much down payment
you'll need to save up but making 150k
you might be able to do this by the end
of next year have your own place with no
debt with a giant pile of cash in the
bank how would that feel now the goal
that's the plan absolutely dude we are
cheering you on hang on the line our
friend austin will pick up on top of
every dollar premium i'm going to gift
you financial peace university i want
you to watch all of those videos it's
going to give you a lot of language and
confidence and education and motivation
you need to actually do this stuff to
make the sacrifices for its short season
so you can win for the rest of your life
we are here for you man thanks so much
for the call thanks for trusting us with
this situation we appreciate you